just another day with kim kardashian hey
guys it's kim kardashian and we're at my
house right now
and i wanted to take you guys in an
inside look of what my everyday life is
especially including the paparazzi the
moment i walk out the door it's crazy so
i wanted to start at my place and see my
journey
into the paparazzi how cool is this limo
all right let's go doing the show
keeping up with the kardashians my
family and i have made ourselves
our life very public um which was you
know
a decision that we chose to make and
hopefully shut down some rumors of what
you know your
stereotypical hollywood kids are like
and um i think we've done a really good
job of showing
you know that we are normal kids we get
up every day we have jobs
you know we i run my stores i don't just
shop all day
and and party all night our first stop
jimmy choo
what's our mission kim picking out some
fabulous things
there may be paparazzi wherever we're
going i mean
um if we're shopping and i have on a bad
outfit no i mean
you never you never get nervous you just
have to be a little bit more careful
because you have to make sure that you
know they're not sneaking in the
dressing rooms or trying to get any
weird shots
that's the only thing you just have to
be aware now you have to be a lot more
cautious
i haven't had a bad experience with
paparazzi yet
they haven't tried to egg me on they'll
definitely ask the questions that they
want to know the answer
or they will twist it and act like it
was a little
nastier to try and get a nasty reaction
out of you
but you just have to kind of know the
game and know what they're about and
know that this is their job
when i was actually holding the camera
and trying to give
you know turn the tables on them and
have a camera they started to get nasty
with me
you know a guy was cursing at me and
yelling at me to take the camera away
and
you know let me see your face and um i'm
just doing to them what they do to me
every single day so i don't know why
they were so nasty about that
but they'll have to deal they do it to
everyone else
i'm obsessed with jimmy choo i don't
know if america knows this but kim
kardashian is an amazing
stylist thank you i started off um
actually it started by
styling my mom and bruce in their
infomercials
how much is this 4 900 i can't fathom
spending
that on a purse i'm also really you know
try to be money conscious thank you kim
you're so nice
we love you kim it does give you an
adrenaline rush where you're
you know you're you're excited but
you're nervous and there's so many
people and how do you see your way out
and you know there's gonna be cameras
this close to your face
that they're gonna get some gross shots
of you and
what can a girl do i just wanted to go
into a store we just left jimmy choos we
have our shoes our handbags
and our sunglasses where are we headed
next so water works
i love just the clear crystal and how
these are stackable
i just love that the white is very
modern very clean there's like so many
so much to choose from i really don't
even know which direction
kim now we've taken care of the shoes
the accessories the home
how about an outfit let's go right
across the street to alice in olivia
perfect i'll start because i know we
gotta go
okay kim we have the outfit and i am
exhausted from all this paparazzi
just another day with kim kardashian